welcome to back to cbs mornings we're
going to begin with this because we're
going to hear from olympic gymnasts and
advocate ali raisman about her very
powerful testimony on capitol hill now
she testified with three other world
champion gymnasts there was simone biles
michaela moroney and maggie nichols they
discussed the investigation into sexual
abuse by former team usa dr larry nassar
this hearing followed a report that
found that two fbi field offices quote
failed to respond to the nassar
allegations with the utmost seriousness
and urgency that the allegations
deserved and required
reisman said that one agent diminished
her abuse and made her feel like it was
not worth pursuing a case
over the past few years it has become
painfully clear
how a survivor's healing is affected by
the handling of their abuse
and it disgusts me
that we are still fighting for the most
basic answers and accountability over
six
years
later
discussed is the word fbi director
christopher wray testified he has no
explanation for the actions of the
agents at those two offices he said the
bureau is taking steps to ensure that
this never happens again
aly raisman joins us now to discuss ali
raisman first i want to say to you thank
you so much for your testimony yesterday
i have to say it was gut-wrenching
but i think it was something that we all
really needed to hear and i really
applaud your bravery for for sitting
there and sharing it with all of us
second i want to know what it took for
you to prepare for yesterday and how you
felt when it was all over the testimony
you said like serving up uh young women
on a silver plat platter to pedophiles
was very very difficult
yeah thank you for asking that question
because i think so many people you know
they they may watch it but they don't
really actually realize how much goes
into it and for me personally i spend so
much time preparing for the testimony
and i i feel like i overthink every
single word and so
it was so draining for me i actually
right now i kind of feel a little bit
like in fight or flight mode so i think
i feel a little bit more awake than i
thought i would because i feel
i don't know if anyone else can relate
to this when you feel so anxious it's
kind of hard to relax and hard to sit
still but
the weeks leading up to preparing for
the testimony was so draining and so
exhausting and it affects me physically
like i have
migraines i am like so tired my body
hurts i feel like i just finished a
training session and um yesterday i left
feeling
more
hopeful than i thought i would i'm
obviously really triggered and exhausted
but it seemed that the senators were
very validating so i'm really hoping
they're going to be able to help us
ali it's great to hear that you're
feeling more more hopeful we heard from
fbi director uh christopher wray who
said it was inexclusive inexcusable the
fbi's behavior he had no explanation and
that steps were being taken to make sure
it never happens again are you aware of
what those steps are have you heard
directly from the fbi
i have not and you know i think
there has been you know a resignation
and and someone was fired but it's it's
similar with um usa gymnastics and usopc
where we don't have explanations and
that leaves us to speculate our
guesswork when we're talking about
children being safe and children being
spared the abuse that i and so many
others endured um we want answers and so
i do want to understand what they're
doing but in order for me to believe in
a safer future we need to be looking at
the fbi usa gymnastics and usopc and
recognizing that there is an interplay
among the three organizations and they
all need to be investigated because if
there is not a true independent
investigation we can't believe in a
safer future so um you know now i'm i'm
hoping that the senators will help us
get that rolling because i don't know
what else to to do from from here if
they're they're not able to help us then
um
i don't i don't know it needs to happen
in my opinion though
simone biles said that she competed in
this year's olympics so this
this wouldn't be swept under the rug
what did you think about what she said
you know i think that simone um
is incredible i'm i'm so
proud of her i'm so proud of maggie and
michaela this is so hard for all of us
you know the last couple of years
watching simone train uh while also
navigating the abuse and for bringing
light to the crisis of abuse in amateur
sports you know listen we all knew that
you all had been let down i think most
of us did not know the extent to how you
all
how the fbi fbi and so many adults let
you all down and i'm wondering how
you're processing this now
yeah i think you know processing this is
is really hard to navigate it it's um
it's hard especially when for so long
i think all of our abuse was really
diminished by
people in big positions of power you
know the fbi u.s olympic committee and
usa gymnastics making us feel like our
abuse wasn't a big deal and so i think
that from personally it's taken a lot of
therapy a lot of time for me to realize
what happened to me was bad and what i
feel
is real and that this is so much bigger
than us and so it's a balance of taking
care of myself and obviously today i
feel like um i need to be taking care of
myself but at the same time we recognize
the importance of
um you know hopefully things are going
to be moving but i think that any time
that we can talk about it it hopefully
helps push for change but you know i
think i keep thinking about
all of the
young survivors out there um and even
just survivors that are adults and just
the message that is being sent by the
fbi in my opinion is just it's horrific
you know it's like it's
public it's um
talking about it is so important and i'm
wondering did you all ever talk to each
other about it it happened to so many
young women did you all ever talk
amongst yourselves or did you all just
think we're the only ones this is
happening to
you know i can recall talking about um
some of our experiences with each other
but because there was not a lot of
conversation around what sexual abuse or
sexual assault was in my mind if i would
ever have conversations with my
teammates
you know i never occurred to me that it
was actual sexual abuse i i recognized
that this wasn't right but i didn't know
what it was and i recognized i was
uncomfortable but at the same time i
thought he's a doctor so i feel guilty
now for distrusting a doctor who am i to
say that what he's doing isn't right and
and honestly it was so normalized in the
most horrific way or when you know
nasser was abusing me he was abusing so
many of my teammates that i thought okay
he it seems he's been doing this for
decades so
if it wasn't right someone would have
said something a long time ago so i'm
the problem i i'm wrong for questioning
him and that's something that i think a
lot of survivors do is we distrust how
we feel ali on the subject of of
survivors you have a documentary coming
out on lifetime in which you spoke to a
number of survivors not only in the
world of gymnastics as i understand it
what did you learn from them
it was you know
working on the darkness to light
documentary um it's a three-hour special
with lifetime that actually airs on
friday september 24th it was
it was just um a really
incredible experience it was obviously
um so many things mixed in one where
it's empowering but it's also
devastating to hear survivors
experiences and something that i learned
from the lifetime show but also even
from yesterday being with my friends and
my teammates is the power of community
and it's so special to be able to
connect with survivors that i've never
met before that we have this special
unspoken bond where i feel like we can
finish each other's sentences they help
me feel valid validated they help me
feel less alone and so i can only hope
that they felt that same thing for me
but it was a really beautiful experience
and i'm so grateful for their time and
for the survivors sharing their stories
and i hope that it helps someone out
there
i i know it will help someone out there
aly raisman again we thank you thank you
for talking yesterday it's so personal
and so private and so painful and yet
you're with us again this morning really
we thank you so much thank you for your
strength okay
nate's right we thank you for your
strength